Professor David Blight:
I want to start with what
many Americans therefore do with
it.
Some of you in this room may
have grown up Civil War buffs,
like I did, I confess.
There are millions of Civil War
tourists.
It has this enduring--the
military history in particular,
the battle history--has an
enduring, eternal hold on our
imagination.
But this is a first for me.
I just got this email,
well, a couple of weeks ago,
from a woman named Nicki
Blackburn in Charleston,
South Carolina;
has her photograph on it.
She's a real estate agent,
a pretty real estate agent.
[Laughter]
And she wanted me to know as a
Civil War historian that she and
her firm have put a twenty-four
hour webcam on the Calhoun
Mansion near Battery Park--on
the cupola of the Calhoun
Mansion--near Battery Park in
Lower Charleston,
which looks out directly onto
Fort Sumter, a mile away,
so that you can dialup on the
Internet and watch Fort Sumter
twenty four hours a day.
[Laughter]
I've experienced a wide variety
of bizarre phenomena about the
Civil War with reenactors,
at sites and so on and so on
and so on.
And if you're on C-SPAN enough
believe me, you get every kind
of late-night,
crazy American writing to you.
But that's a first.
Twenty-four hours,
webcam, Fort Sumter.
I don't know what the hell
you're supposed to see.
[Laughter]
Maybe there are ghosts of
Confederates that come out at
night, and if they have the
right kind of night
vision…God I don't know.
But she's serious!
I'm sorry.
All right.
In 1863, on the beautiful
little hilltop cemetery on the
south edge of the town of
Gettysburg,
Pennsylvania--a small,
sleepy town with a large
population of German immigrants,
a couple of little shoe
factories, a crossroads town,
a market town--they had a
cemetery in this beautiful
setting.
And, over the archway,
or as part of the archway into
that cemetery that would soon
become famous,
there was a sign that read,
quote, "All persons found using
firearms on these grounds will
be prosecuted within the utmost
rigor of the law."
Irony makes the world go 'round.
Okay, today I want to take up
with you at least the beginnings
of the question of Confederate
defeat and Union victory.
We're going to focus in
particular on battlefronts.
There are numerous reasons,
explanations,
causal interpretations for
Confederate defeat and Union
victory that have flowed forth
in Civil War scholarship for
years.
And we began to have a new kind
of heated argument about it,
at least in books,
about 10 years ago,
in part because of a series of
two books by historians named
Hattaway and Beringer.
They wrote two big tomes.
One was entitled Why the
North Won the Civil War,
and the other was entitled
Why the South Lost the Civil
War;
not very subtle titles.
And they were the ones who
posited, more than anyone ever
had before, in a much more
sophisticated way--and I want to
come back to that,
and it's part of exactly what's
at stake in these two wonderful
books you're reading,
or have read,
or are about to read,
by Drew Faust and Gary
Gallagher.
Gallagher's Confederate
War and Faust's Mothers
of Invention take up this
question of the so-called loss
of will.
Did the South lose the Civil
War because it ultimately lost
its will to sustain the fight?
There are many sides to that
argument, and I'll take it up in
a moment.
I want to do--.
Well anyway,
the Civil War,
as we've said many times,
is the first great photographed
event of American history.
There are thousands of
photographs.
We'd have had thousands more if
people hadn't destroyed so many
of them.
And, of course,
Ken Burns's film series is in
part--in great part--reliant on
those photographs,
and he and his cameramen,
of course, they have cameras
now that can take right inside
almost these old daguerreotypes
and tintypes and make them live
in ways that they didn't at the
time.
But that's an image of soldiers
at the front,
smoking a pipe,
petting his dog.
It's an officer whose wife has
come to the front,
of course.
It's winter quarters,
near Culpepper Courthouse,
Virginia, 1863.
They always built these cabins
with these chimneys.
They built thousands of these,
with barrels on top;
those are their chimneys.
Since I've been discussing this
question of mobilization,
there are many,
many images in the war,
from the war,
that show this kind of
industrial might of the North.
There's incredible photographs
of the James River landings in
Virginia by 1864,
and just as far as the horizon
can see supplies,
the materiel piled up all over
the wharves.
This is an image in Virginia of
the wagon trains of the Potomac,
Army of the Potomac,
by 1864, thousands of wagons.
This is mobilization for total
war.
And I just for the sake of
reality want to show that also
photographers,
like Matthew Brady and
Alexander Gardner and their
troops of photographers--it was
Gardner in particular who went
to Gettysburg after the Battle
of Gettysburg and photographed
so many of them,
so many of the dead.
This is a soldier,
a Union soldier,
killed at Gettysburg.
It became a kind of macabre
fascination, especially in the
North where these photographs
were often displayed publicly.
Brady first started doing it in
'62 and early '63,
and hence that famous comment
by,
I believe, George Templeton
Strong who said it was Brady who
brought the war into people's
homes,
into their living rooms,
if they went to witness these
photographs.
Now, more on that perhaps at
the end.
But go back with me now to this
question of Union victory,
Confederate defeat.
We're not going to end the war
today, that's next week,
and we're going to take the war
today through 1863,
and major military turning
points where you can begin to
make an argument,
from this point forward.
From this point forward,
it would be very difficult for
the Confederacy to win,
although not impossible,
as we'll see in 1864.
Now on any list--and I'm going
to just give you a list out
front and then we'll kind of
take up some of them--but on any
list of why the North wins and
why the South loses,
of course, are these elements:
One, resources and numbers.
It goes without saying in a
world of war that is becoming
more industrialized,
more modern in its weaponry
and, to some extent,
its tactics--although that's
one of the reasons,
of course, casualties in this
war were so ghastly because they
were fighting with much more
modern weapons,
repeating rifles and of course
the rifled musket that could
actually hit something at 800
yards and it could be deadly at
2 to 300 yards.
Think of that, 2 to 300 yards.
You could hit something and see
it.
But they were fighting with old
tactics, line upon line,
shoulder to shoulder,
double ranks.
If the front of the rank fell,
the second rank was supposed to
be there, and they were supposed
to have loaded their rifles in
time to be up front while the
other ones went back and
reloaded again,
and that a veteran soldier in
this war could load his muzzle
loader--you had to load the
minie ball and the cap,
back here, and then with your
ramrod--a veteran soldier could
do that without pressure about
three times a minute.
Of course under the pressure of
battle and being shot at and the
cacophony of sound and the
terror and fear a soldier went
though,
sometimes they couldn't perform
that.
And all over battlefields in
this war they would find dead
soldiers sometimes with a rifle
they had loaded three and four
times, and never fired.
They just kept loading.
They'd sort of lose their minds.
But in a war that is now fought
with such weaponry--and it's
going to depend on industrial
production--there is an argument
that this war was won by the
North in the shoe factories of
Lowell,
Massachusetts,
or the gun factories of New
Haven, or the gun factories of
Springfield, Mass,
in the sheer productive--or on
those railroads of the North,
which was so much better,
more efficient,
than the railroads of the
South.
There's certainly an argument
for that.
Now, that handwriting was on
the wall from the beginning of
the war.
In a lovely old book that David
Donald did once called Why
the North Won,
he quotes on the first page of
the book a newspaper in
Lynchburg, Virginia,
summer 1861;
the Battle of Bull Run hasn't
even happened yet,
and all this fury for war.
The editor of the Lynchburg
Virginian wrote,
quote: "Dependent upon Europe
and the North for almost every
yard of cloth and every coat and
boot and hat that we wear,
for our axes,
scythes, tubs and buckets,
in short for everything except
our bread and meat,
it must occur to the South that
if our relations with the North
are ever severed we
should"--they'd already been
severed--"we should in all the
South not be able to clothe
ourselves.
We could not fill our
firesides, plow our fields,
nor mow our meadows.
In fact, we should be reduced
to a state more abject than we
are willing to look at,
even prospectively,
and yet all these things
staring us in the face,
we shut our eyes and we go in
blindfold."
Man, was that prescient.
One of the most remarkable
facts about the American Civil
War--and James McPherson makes a
big deal of this in Battle
Cry of Freedom,
over and over--is that despite
their lack of the industrial
productivity in relation to the
North,
it is amazing how long the
South held out and amazing how
close they actually came to
winning their version or
definition of victory.
The North had more banking,
more labor capacity,
everything.
Two, an argument has always
been made that the North in the
end had superior political
leadership, i.e.,
Abraham Lincoln.
Now a lot can be made of this,
and a lot has been made of
this, in book after book
comparing Lincoln with Davis.
And there's no question that as
an executive,
as a leader,
as a politician,
as a manipulator of people,
in terms of an acumen,
even a genius for politics and
organization,
Abraham is about as good as
we've ever had.
Jefferson Davis,
on the other hand,
smart and brilliant man that he
was, a long military career,
long service in the Senate,
the War Department and all
else, was nevertheless not a
very good executive.
He always had one foot sort of
tied in the States' Rights
tradition, and that other foot
now,
really where his soul was by
1862, '63, '64,
was in trying to create a
nation,
a centralized nation state,
doing all the things that the
States' Rights tradition said he
should not.
He was not in the end a great
war President,
in part, some have argued,
because he would have preferred
to be on the battlefield and not
in an executive's role.
He listened to those generals
who were his friends and didn't
tend to listen to those who were
not.
He often made sort of
leadership mistakes such as the
time he personally went out
West--I'll come to that in a
moment--during the,
just before the great campaign
for Chattanooga,
in late summer and then the
fall of 1863,
for the possession of this
terribly important strategic
crossroads in southeast
Tennessee,
to the gateway into the Deep
South, the crossroads of two
great southern rivers,
the crossroads of the two main
east/west southern railroads and
so on.
He goes out there in the wake
of the fall of Chattanooga,
when Braxton Bragg's army had
to retreat south,
and he goes to the
whole--there'd been terrible
dissention in that Confederate
Army.
All the generals wanted Bragg
fired and Davis goes out
personally to the camp and
gathers all the generals around
him,
with Bragg standing there,
and asked all the other
generals whether they thought
they should have a new
commander.
And to a man they basically all
said "yes," in front of their
commander.
And then Davis re-appointed him.
It was one of the most bizarre
decisions of the war.
Bragg was a disaster.
But this is the sort of thing
that--and Davis and Bragg went
back years and they were old
friends.
And Davis made some strange
decisions.
But Davis also was handicapped
tremendously,
politically,
by this States' Rights
tradition.
And I would argue one other
thing;
and it's really a third reason
you can put on this long list of
why the North's going to win
this war.
The North had an existing
political culture,
it had an existing political
party system.
Now we can argue that that
political party system was
greatly divided,
and it was.
By '63 you've got what are
called Peace Democrats.
The Democratic Party in the
North is beginning to argue for
a negotiated peace,
an end to the war;
a divided America,
a Confederate States of America
and a United States of America.
And in 1864 they're going to
run McClellan on that
platform--and we'll talk about
how pivotal the '64 Election was
next week.
But you had an existing party
system that could organize
politics, that could organize
dissent,
that could channel opposition,
and it also gave Abraham
Lincoln the cudgel or the whip
of partisanship.
He could build enough of a
coalition to sustain not only
the war effort but also to pull
off some of that remarkable
legislation that I started to
talk about last time,
especially economic
legislation, that really in some
ways, for awhile at least,
transformed the American
central government.
Fourth, one of the principle
reasons the North's going to win
this war is that it does
ultimately,
through some remarkable
diplomacy--especially by Charles
Francis Adams in London,
the U.S.
Ambassador to Great Britain,
grandson of John Adams,
son of John Quincy--the fact
that in the end the Union
government succeeds in keeping
Great Britain ostensibly out of
the war,
at least militarily,
mostly, out of the war,
is absolutely crucial to Union
victory.
Had Britain--had Lee won at
Antietam--and this is what
McPherson means,
and many other historians were
really doing this before Jim
was,
but he's made it his own
argument--that you can't
understand Union victory and
Confederate defeat without
dealing with all kinds of
contingencies,
moments in the war.
If this hadn't happened then,
that can't happen;
if that doesn't happen then,
that can't happen.
And so putting your eggs in any
one basket to explain this,
or for that matter anything in
history, is a bad idea.
But one of those contingencies
is if Lee wins at Antietam,
succeeds in moving further into
the North,
threatens Northern cities,
and the British government
formally recognized the
Confederacy and formally sent
British troops to fight with the
Confederacy--rather than just in
a sense sending them a shadow
navy,
which was helping the
Confederacy, and building them
ships--could've had a very
different outcome to this war.
If the United States had had to
fight a second front,
in Canada, against the British,
just imagine the possible
outcomes.
So, a very important factor.
Fifth, much has always been
made about the so called,
in the end, superior military
leadership of the North,
in the end.
And we'll deal with this much
more next week,
and a little bit today,
when Grant and Sherman and
Sheridan and General Thomas and
a few others actually finally
become the principal leaders of
this entire,
ultimately coordinated West and
East strategic effort against
the South, you can
argue--although I think too much
is often made of this--you can
argue that in some ways Grant
won the war.
There are books that literally
argue that, that want to give
Grant in so many ways credit for
Union victory,
and that will argue--and I'll
come back to this next
week--that in some ways,
as great as Robert E.
Lee was as a battlefield
commander, as daring as he was,
the risks that he took,
the ability he had to somehow
see a terrain,
to see land,
to see the possibilities of a
landscape and how to move huge
numbers of men through it,
and the way that he could
inspire through a quite amazing
level of charisma his officer
staff--there's a lot to the fact
that Robert E.
Lee himself had a lot to do
with sustaining the Confederate
war effort as long as it lasted.
And Gary Gallagher's going to
make a pretty big deal of that
in your book Confederate
War.
It's just worth remembering
that Gallagher's source set by
and large is the officer corps
of Lee's army.
It's a fine book but you got to
remember where his sources are
coming from.
These are Lee's lieutenants
that he's quoting over and over
and over, and they become about
as loyal to a military commander
as anyone has ever been in
American history.
And then sixth,
or whatever number I'm on--and
we've dealt with this a good
deal already,
we'll come back to it
later--the policy of
emancipation,
the transformation of this war
into far beyond its original
limited aims,
into a war that will become a
war of conquest.
A war, as Lincoln comes to
define it in late '62,
and it's absolutely clear in
'63,
has to be a war to the ultimate
aim of the unconditional
surrender of the South,
which means a war on their
resources, on their society,
on their transportation
systems,
and on slavery--their labor
system, their greatest source of
wealth--and war on their cities,
the people;
or as Sherman will say,
he wanted to make Georgia howl.
All right, now that's a short
list.
Now fold into that this
theory--it's a theory--that in
the end, you add all this
up--resources,
political leadership,
military leadership,
the policy of unconditional
surrender,
emancipation,
keeping Great Britain out of
the war, diplomacy and so on and
so on,
and battlefield victories,
as I'll point out in a
second--you get this argument
for the loss of morale,
loss of will.
Now, this was fashioned by
historians really who cut their
teeth on the Vietnam Era.
And they argue that there are
plenty of examples throughout
history of insurgencies like the
Confederacy--that's what it was,
it's a big one,
it's not just a little guerilla
army pecking away at oil
lines--but they argue that there
are many cases in history.
And the most obvious one in the
1970s and '80s to Americans was
North Vietnam,
which held out for a
generation, really two
generations, against the French
Empire and then against the
United States of America,
the biggest military machine in
the world.
They lost three and half
million people,
and they won.
So suddenly through that
experience, through those eyes,
some American historians began
to look back at the Civil War
and say, "You know what?
Well wait a minute here,
why didn't the Confederacy hold
out even longer?"
Yes, there were bread riots,
there was some starvation,
there was a hell of a lot of
desertion, but maybe that's
telling us something.
That in the end it wasn't just
Marse Robert and his loyal men,
it was the civilians behind the
war, it was the home front.
This is what Drew Faust went to
all these women's diaries to try
to test, and the argument
essentially is that the South
didn't have a sufficient degree
of nationalism,
of an emotional psychological
devotion to a historic nation
state that they would do
anything to save and preserve,
in the ways,
let's say, that the Germans did
to the absolute bitter end
against the Russians and the
Allies on the Western Front in
the Second World War.
Beringer and Hattaway love the
example of Paraguay;
nobody knows anything about the
story of Paraguay and the way it
held out against Brazil,
I think it was,
as an early twentieth century
example.
And there've been other kinds
of guerrilla insurgencies over
the years.
At the bottom of this argument
was why didn't more Confederate
forces, rather than surrender,
go off and form guerrilla
bands?
Why didn't the American Civil
War end the way so many civil
wars end--they never quite end?
A band of twenty men here and
300 there, going off into the
hills, supplying themselves
somehow,
forming a kind of alternative
insurgency that never quite
dies.
You read a lot of lost cause
literature by the late
nineteenth century and you would
almost think that is what
happened.
But it didn't happen.
And Beringer and Hattaway have
also argued that,
in part, the South,
once it begins to lose the war
in '63 and '64,
that it was Southern Unionists
that began to come to the fore,
that there were large--and
there were--large pockets of
unionism,
people who didn't really
support the Confederate war
effort, in western Virginia and
western North Carolina,
eastern Tennessee,
upland Georgia,
in those hills that Sherman's
Army begins to move through and
discovers there's some white
folk around who want to support
him.
In fact, Sherman was much
kinder to those Georgia whites
than he was to those Georgia
blacks who tried to gain freedom
by coming to his army.
More on Sherman's racism next
week.
Now, in the end this is an
argument that what the South
lacked was a deep mystical
emotional level of nationalism.
Well that's been countered,
that's been countered by
numerous historians.
Drew Faust is one of them,
in an earlier book called
The Creation of Confederate
Nationalism.
She's been joined,
or she actually joined a whole
group of historians studying
this idea.
It's been one of the recurring,
fascinating questions about the
Civil War, and the question is
essentially what kind of
nationalism did the Confederacy
actually develop?
After all, it only lasted four
years.
The question really is,
was there a confederate nation
or were they just a band of
states that came together in
military defense of homeland?
Well there are arguments on all
sides of this.
And I'll just say a couple of
things.
I think those--and it's Drew
Faust, it's John McCardell,
numerous historians.
The weight of the best
argument, I think,
is that the South did indeed,
rather quickly--and there's a
lot of lessons in this
historically--develop a serious
level of this mystical kind of
nationalism.
They developed an ideology that
they said their nation was based
on.
They said right up front,
at the beginning of the war,
Jefferson Davis,
speech after speech after
speech,
he said the Confederacy is the
logical vessel of the American
Revolution;
what the Confederacy really was
was the carryover of 1776.
1861 was 1776.
That George Washington,
they will argue,
was the founder of the
Confederacy.
That true American democracy
was in this resistance to
centralization.
They created seals and songs
and images and heroes and
paintings, poetry,
all over the place.
They used religion,
the same kind of millennial
Christianity.
The same kind of theory of a
divine providence that
Northerners are praying to and
arguing for is the same kind of
millennialism that Confederates
are going to argue for.
They're going to say that they
are the chosen nation.
All over the place,
among Southern clergy,
that argument is put forth,
especially early in the war.
And then lastly, slavery.
It is in some ways almost
amazing how much Southerners
began to defend slavery and the
ways they began to defend
slavery,
during the war,
and the ways that they began to
link it to their nation,
the Confederacy,
of how the Confederacy was put
into this world to perfect
slavery, to improve it,
to show the world that this
slave society,
this system,
this biracial system where one
race is the labor and the other
race is the educated,
to show the world the
possibilities of that.
They even developed a whole
variety of traveling Confederate
minstrel groups.
Minstrelsy had been primarily a
phenomenon of the North.
Often the audiences were
largely white working class,
but during the war suddenly you
had these Confederate troops of
minstrels,
all over the place,
and new songs and new poems
were written that were tied now
to the sort of fate of the
Confederacy.
I'll just give you one example.
There was one minstrel troop
known as--these were whites in
blackface, keeping morale up.
One of them was called
Lincoln's Intelligent
Contrabands, and one little
verse ran: "I'd rather work the
cotton patch and dine on corn
and bacon than live up North on
good white bread of abolition
makin'."
And it gets worse and it goes
on and on.
And the story or the argument
of all these Confederate
minstrel songs and the poetry
they're based on is that black
people don't want to be free.
They don't want anything to do
with this free labor nonsense,
they want to stay where they
are.
Now, I invite you to read
Gallagher and Faust on this.
And Gallagher's going to make a
pretty aggressive argument
against the loss of will thesis,
and he's going to argue that
Confederate nationalism
ultimately resided in those
armies,
the armies that stuck it out
against almost unbelievable
odds.
All right, but in 1863 the war
had major military turning
points.
And let me take you through
some of that,
well the three major ones,
with some dispatch.
But these are,
on that short list of I believe
five major turning points in the
Civil War, I mentioned
Gettysburg and Vicksburg.
Well, kind of add to that,
if you would,
the fall of Port Hudson,
only a week after Vicksburg out
on the Mississippi,
and then the ultimate fall,
final fall of Chattanooga to
Union hands by the fall of 1863.
Now, some maps are in order.
The Confederacy won a major
victory at the Battle of
Chancellorsville near----just
west of Fredericksburg the first
week of May 1863.
This was yet again--you'll
remember the whole,
the previous year,
a year before this,
McClellan had invaded the
peninsula up toward Richmond,
the Seven Days Campaign and all
the rest,
defeated, retreated.
Lee then invaded the North.
He's going to do exactly the
same thing in the summer of
1863, in the wake of what was
truly,
without a question,
a decisive victory at
Chancellorsville.
Lee held a Council of War in
Richmond with Davis and other
generals.
This time, of course,
Stonewall Jackson was not
there;
he was shot and killed by his
own men, after the battle,
at night, of Chancellorsville.
He lived about a week.
That little house where he died
and they amputated his arm is a
shrine today.
If you want to see some Civil
War weirdness go to the
Stonewall Jackson shrine.
And if you ever saw the movie,
if you ever endured the movie
Gods and Generals,
all 4½
hours of it,
which I did because I had to
write a review of it,
you know that they took almost
a half hour to have Stonewall
Jackson die.
[Laughter]
I'm sorry, for those of you who
are Stonewall Jackson fans.
It's just quite remarkable.
But at any rate,
Lee lost a terribly important
commander then,
there's no question about it,
and it will always live in
Southern lore--what if Jackson
had lived?
Or what if he'd had Jackson at
Gettysburg?
What if he'd had Jackson at
Cold Harbor, wherever?
At any rate,
Lee went to Davis and said,
"Let me invade the North
again."
Davis was a little cautious
because the first time it didn't
work and he almost lost the war
a year ago.
James Longstreet,
now second-in-command to Lee in
the Army of Northern Virginia,
had another idea,
and Longstreet almost always
did.
And there's a whole debate in
Civil War military history about
just whether Longstreet should
have been listened to throughout
'63.
Longstreet's idea was to take
at least two divisions,
if not an entire corps of
infantry,
as many as possible--20,000
men--and move them out West,
because Longstreet worried that
the war was being lost in the
West.
And you know what?
He was right on that.
But Lee said no.
And always in Civil War
scholarship there's been this
question, did Lee ultimately
lose the war because of his
obsession with Virginia,
his home state,
his homeland,
in not allowing Confederate
troops to be moved West?
Well they weren't moved West,
not at this point in time.
All over the war now,
even though Lee had won this
major victory at
Chancellorsville,
the Confederacy was potentially
hemmed in, potentially.
So Lee's response to this was
daring, and had he won at
Gettysburg decisively we
wouldn't be--well I don't what
we'd be debating;
I'm not sure I want to know
what we'd be debating.
But Lee did decide to go West,
up over into the Upper
Shenandoah Valley and invade
this time all the way into
Pennsylvania,
which he did in June, 1863.
Lincoln's Commander of the Army
of the Potomac,
now seriously defeated,
was a general named Hooker.
Hooker resigned on the 28^(th)
of June 1863 and was replaced by
a general named George Gordon
Meade,
only three days before what
would become the greatest battle
of the war.
What Gettysburg became was in
some ways an attempt by the
Union armies----it's an effort
by the Union armies,
blue here, of course,
to catch up with Lee's army as
they invaded up into
Pennsylvania,
and to stay between Lee's army
and Washington DC.
It's in some ways a replay of
what had happened just the year
before.
Now, they actually ended up
meeting at this little town of
Gettysburg almost by mistake;
they hadn't planned that.
Lee wanted to move all of his
troops into Central
Pennsylvania.
The whole idea here was to live
off the land and the rich
farmland of Pennsylvania,
to take the war out of ravaged
Central Virginia,
relieve Richmond,
and Lee believed,
tap into the war weariness of
the North and possibly even
reinvigorate British
intervention.
There wasn't a lot of
likelihood at that point,
but he hoped at any rate that
there might be some possibility.
It was a great calculated risk.
Had it worked, who knows?
It did not.
They collided near Gettysburg
because a group of Confederate
infantry were marching toward
the town from the West on July
1,1863, because they'd heard
there were shoes in Gettysburg.
And they were confiscating,
by the way, everything--cattle,
hogs, food, everything they
could take from Pennsylvania
farms.
And rather than tapping into
war weariness in the North,
what Lee accomplished was to
stimulate resistance in the
North.
Nothing like an army invading
your land and stealing your
animals to cause you some
consternation.
Lee's army also took scores of
free blacks, living in southern
and central Pennsylvania,
and shuttled them quickly back
into the South as slaves.
And when this got into the
press it also had an effect on
Northern morale.
The first day at
Gettysburg--and I can't go into
the kind of detail I'd love to
here,
and I know some of you would
like me to, although I'm going
to invite those of you who are
military history enthusiasts to
an evening session,
perhaps next week,
perhaps the week after,
on a Wednesday,
if anybody wants,
where we can go into more
detail on this and you can open
your veins and get a really good
shot of military history,
if you'd like.
[Laughter]
And if you OD,
that's your fault.
The first day at Gettysburg was
a Confederate victory,
almost a complete rout.
It's actually nighttime that
stopped it.
The second day at Gettysburg,
if you look at this map over
here, you'll note that the Union
battle line--the Union Army
barely got there in time,
by the second day,
to actually oppose Lee's Army.
They had marched all day.
Some of these Union troops had
marched 30 miles in a day just
to get there.
But the second day at
Gettysburg were attacks,
massive attacks,
on the two ends of the line,
the left flank and the right
flank of the Union armies,
which were both very high
ground.
How many of you have been to
Gettysburg?
You know Little Round Top and
Culp's Hill then--large hills.
Huge battles were fought on
those hills on July 2,1862,
with huge numbers of
casualties, especially for the
Confederates.
By the third day,
Longstreet urged vehemently
that Lee retreat,
a strategic retreat,
and move south,
southward, and then toward
Washington and threaten the U.S.
capital, but to choose other
ground to fight on because of
the way these hills and ridges
were set up in front of them.
Longstreet counseled a kind of
strategic defensive move.
They are on enemy's land,
enemy territory.
Every day is a total risk here,
and they've got a real problem
with their supply line.
But Lee said no,
his blood was up,
and there's evidence all over
the dispatches,
Lee wanted to win there,
he wanted to fight.
And I'll come back to this
question next week about Lee's
own psyche for war and what they
said happened to his eyes when
it was time for battle.
So, on the third day at
Gettysburg he ordered a
concentration at the center and
it became the largest military
assault of the war,
the largest infantry assault of
the Civil War.
It's known as Pickett's Charge
because it's named for one of
the three Division Commanders
who led it,
George Pickett--who hid behind
a barn through the whole damn
thing, by the way--while two of
his brigade commanders were
killed,
and all of the thirteen
colonels in his brigade were
killed or wounded.
So Pickett's Charge,
the charge of 13,000 men,
for one hour,
across a wide open field,
slightly rising toward a ridge,
lasted about one hour,
and almost exactly one-half of
those 13,000 men were killed or
wounded and never got back to
the ridge they started from.
It was Lee's greatest mistake
in the Civil War.
He knew it.
He rode out in the middle of
this field when the thing was
over, as the men were straggling
back,
those who survived,
and he kept going up to them
and saying, "It's all my fault,
it's all my fault,
it's all my fault.
Please help me."
He even offered his resignation
to Jefferson Davis a couple of
weeks later, but of course Davis
wasn't going to take it.
The great significance of
Gettysburg is many things,
it's several things.
It's the greatest battle of the
war in terms of its sheer scale.
Casualties were ghastly;
28,000 casualties in three
days--that's dead,
wounded and missing--on the
Confederate side.
One-third of all the men
engaged were dead or wounded at
the end of it.
On the Union side there were
23,000 casualties;
that's one of every four.
My guy, Charlie Brewster,
whose letters I edited,
was actually held in reserve.
They didn't even get there in
time.
The 10^(th) Mass was brought
out to be burial crews,
and his letters about the
fields at Gettysburg are just
quite--almost unbelievable.
There's a particularly poignant
letter where he--they always
rifled the pockets of the
dead--he rifles the pockets of a
dead Confederate soldier and in
his pockets is a letter,
a love letter home.
And he reads that letter and he
quotes from it,
to his own mother,
and then he buries the guy and
saved the letter.
And this was his job for about
three days in a rainstorm,
burying Union and Confederate
dead.
It is the carnage at
Gettysburg, the vast number of
dead, 56-odd-thousand casualties
overall,
that forced the United States
Government to create to the
first national cemetery which
would be created at Gettysburg,
and that's, of course,
why Lincoln went there the next
fall to give the Gettysburg
Address.
Now, but strategically it's
hugely important.
Lee had to retreat as fast as
he could.
The great problem now for the
next week was whether Meade,
the Union Commander,
would follow this up and push
like hell, in spite of how badly
hurt his army was.
And Lincoln was sending
dispatch after dispatch to
Meade, "Please move,
you've got them in
your"--Lincoln was saying things
like,
"You've got them in your grip.
Destroy them.
The war will be over,
the war will be over."
And Meade didn't move for three
days, and Lee's Army escaped on
the 13^(th) and 14^(th) of July,
on a pontoon bridge they
hastily managed to build;
what was left of Lee's Army
managed to get across the
Potomac River and back into
Virginia to fight again.
Gettysburg's a major Union
victory, but it could've been
even bigger.
Out West--and terribly
important, you could argue even
more important--were the sieges
and the capture of two major
places,
I guess you'd call them
fortresses or ports,
along the Mississippi River,
Vicksburg and Port Hudson.
Vicksburg was laid under
siege--Vicksburg had been
brought under siege for months
by a Union Army Commander,
by Ulysses Grant.
They had even at one point
tried to alter the course of the
Mississippi River,
with the biggest military
engineering scheme the world had
ever hatched.
And it didn't really work.
That's a big river -- don't
mess with it.
But finally Grant was able to
put Vicksburg,
in the spring of 1863,
under siege,
mostly from the east,
and it was especially under
complete lockdown siege from May
22 to the first week of July,
in which time the civilian
population of Vicksburg that was
left, and a roughly 30,000
garrison of the Confederate
Army, began to starve.
The civilians were living in
caves because much of their
housing was destroyed by
artillery bombardment.
On June 28 the Confederate
Commander John Pemberton
received a petition from his own
troops,
signed by lots of them,
which said in part,
quote, "If you cannot feed us
you had better surrender."
And so Pemberton sued for--he
didn't sue--he asked for
surrender terms.
He met with Grant on the 3^(rd)
of July, the same afternoon as
Pickett's Charge is happening in
the East--they don't know
it--and Pemberton surrendered
30,000 Confederate troops in the
blink of an eye,
on July 4^(th),
1863.
Central Mississippi would
within weeks be abandoned by
Confederate forces and the whole
of central and northern
Mississippi would come under
Union control.
And that is,
by the way folks,
the most densely populated
slave region anywhere in the
South,
and it is the escape of slaves
now, by the hundreds and then
thousands, into Grant's lines,
that forced his hand in the
creation of numerous contraband
camps all over northern
Mississippi and Tennessee and
even down the Mississippi.
A few days later,
on July 8, at Port Hudson,
down the Mississippi,
just north of Baton Rouge,
a second fort surrendered.
It too had been under siege
since May.
And when Port Hudson
surrendered, the Mississippi
River now was completely in
Union hands and Union control.
On the 16^(th) of July a
merchant steamboat tied up in
New Orleans, having successfully
traveled from St.
Louis all the way down the
river, unharassed at all,
by Confederate guns,
and Lincoln famously wrote his
memo or telegraph to Grant
saying,
"Now the father of waters again
goes unvexed to the sea."
It's terribly important because
if you just look at a map you
realize now, that by controlling
the entire Mississippi River and
the region around it,
you not only are sowing havoc
into Southern society,
freeing slaves,
confiscating land and property,
controlling the South's
greatest seaports,
but you've cut the Confederacy
in half.
And one of the Confederacy's
largest supply lines was through
Texas.
They were actually being
supported, to this point in
time, by the French through
Mexico;
well, that was a supply line
that never worked terribly well.
Now, the clock is running out
on me.
That's okay because what
happens at Chattanooga doesn't
happen--that's the end of 1863,
which is a nice place to pick
it up next time.
But let me leave you with this.
Across the South this was
horrible news,
and especially when
Chattanooga's going to fall in
the fall, it's even worse news.
And these kinds of expressions
now came from Southern leaders
and privates in the Army and
women at home.
And here comes your loss of
morale thesis.
On July 28^(th),
after the fall of Port Hudson
and Vicksburg and the debacle,
the disaster at Gettysburg,
the Confederate
Chief-of-Ordinance,
Josiah Gorgas,
wrote into his diary.
Quote: "Events have succeeded
one another with disastrous
rapidity.
One brief month ago we were
apparently at the point of
success.
Lee was in Pennsylvania
threatening Harrisburg and even
Philadelphia.
Vicksburg seemed to laugh at
all of Grant's efforts to scorn.
Now the picture is just as
somber as it was bright then.
It seems incredible that human
power could effect such a change
in so brief a space.
Yesterday we rode on the
pinnacle of success.
Today absolute ruin seems to be
our portion.
The Confederacy totters to its
destruction."
The war isn't over.
And I'll argue next week the
Confederacy still could have won
its version of victory in 1864.
But those battlefield successes
of '63 were handwriting on the
wall.